lavora nel marketing ma la mia prima
passione è la psicologia è una cosa che
la psicologia mi ha insegnato è che
questa domanda non ha minimamente senso
e non ha senso intanto perché la
risposta è ovvio
certo che siamo irrazionali tra poco
vedremo perché e poi perché comunque ci
sarà sempre chi vi risponderà di no o
perché non lo vuole ammettere o più
semplicemente perché non se ne rende
conto
ma scusate quante cose
compriamo d'impulso senza averlo
programmato non lo abbiamo deciso prima
semplicemente entriamo in quel negozio e
nella nostra testa scatta qualcosa
quante cose compriamo che non ci servono
da un punto di vista oggettivo non è che
abbiano un'utilità pratica però ci fanno
sentire in un certo modo e quante volte
scegliamo un prodotto più che altro per
il significato che ha per noi perché ci
trasmette un emozione beh il mondo del
lusso ad esempio vende solo se crea
emozioni
pensiamo a ferrari quanto incide sulle
vendite di ferrari il fatto che guidare
una ferrari generi automaticamente
ammirazione da parte degli altri
eppure una certa invidia rispetto alla
potenza del motore alle performance
dell'auto al design
quanto incide l'ammirazione perché alla
fine dai lo sappiamo benissimo che le
emozioni influiscono su quello che
desideriamo e su quello che alla fine
compriamo
ed è proprio perché ne siamo consapevoli
che tutto sommato ci sentiamo abbastanza
in controllo della situazione
però adesso vi faccio una domanda chi di
voi beve coca cola alzate pure la mano
coca cola di qualsiasi tipo light 0 ok
chi di voi deve pepsi
ok quindi direi che la maggior parte di
voi preferisce coca cola rispetto a
pezzi
questo fatto che sorprende sembra ovvio
no è ovvio ma perché è ovvio perché la
maggior parte di noi preferisce coca
cola rispetto a persi non è ovviamente
questa domanda se l'è fatta pepsico
l'azienda produttrice della pepsi che ha
cercato di capirlo con una serie di
esperimenti
il primo risale al 1975 pensate ed era
un esperimento molto semplice le persone
dovevano assaggiare tua bevande la coca
cola e la pepsi e le dovevano assaggiare
mentre erano ben date per cui non
sapevano esattamente che cosa stessero
venendo dopodiché ognuno veniva chiesto
quale delle due bevande che appena
assaggiato preferisci e la maggior parte
di loro
rispondeva che la bevanda che gli
piaceva di più era la pepsi questo era
molto strano perché bastava guardare le
vendite di coca cola rispetto a pepsi
per capire che la preferenza dei
consumatori era evidente allora pepsico
decide di rifare lo stesso esperimento
ma questa volta solo metà dei
partecipanti vengono bendati gli altri
semplicemente vedono quello che stanno
vivendo
e anche questa volta la maggior parte
delle persone dice di preferire pepsi ma
delle persone bendate perché negli altri
in coloro che vedono quello che stanno
bevendo il risultato si ribalta il 75
per cento dice di preferire coca cola e
il perché si poteva vedere proprio da
loro cervello perché durante
l'esperimento sono state usate delle
macchine che registrano l'attività
cerebrale dei partecipanti mentre bevono
le due bevande e quello che hanno visto
che quando le persone avevano coca cola
sapendo che si tratta di una coca cola
si attiva un'area del cervello che si
chiama amigdala che è quella che
controlla le emozioni la stessa cosa non
succede quando le persone avevano la
pepsi questo che significa significa che
il perché di buona parte di quelle
risposte preferisco coca cola non è
nient'altro che
el'emozione di coca cola è la felicità è
la magia del natale è il divertimento
con gli amici la libertà la
spensieratezza e la gioia di stare
insieme di ritornare in famiglia e da
decenni che queste immagini queste scene
suscitano in noi delle emozioni che oggi
automaticamente associamo a coca cola e
che sono il motivo per cui la scegliamo
anche se non ce ne rendiamo conto
perché la maggior parte delle volte in
realtà non ce ne rendiamo conto
siamo guidati dalle emozioni non solo
quando vogliamo comprare un'automobile o
un gioiello un orologio un capo di alta
moda
siamo guidati dalle emozioni
praticamente tutti i giorni molto più
spesso di quanto crediamo anche negli
acquisti più frequenti anche nei più
banali
tutti i prodotti che conosciamo nella
nostra mente sono in qualche modo legati
a un emozione e questa emozione
a crearla è proprio la pubblicità mentre
ci racconta quel prodotto e il fatto di
essere continuamente ripetutamente
esposti a queste due cose insieme
il prodotto è l'emozione fa sì che a un
certo punto l'associazione diventi
automatica e la sola vista di quel
prodotto di quel nome
a volte basta un logo diventa
sufficiente per provocare noi
quell'emozione
ecco questo meccanismo un nome in
psicologia si chiama condizionamento e
siamo tutti condizionati dalla
pubblicità ed al marketing che vengono
fatti che sono stati fatti nel tempo
sulle cose che compriamo ok ma quindi
che cosa dovremmo pensare che il
marketing e la pubblicità usano la
nostra psicologia e usano le nostre
emozioni per manipolarci nelle scelte
senza che ce ne rendiamo conto e magari
pure contro il nostro interesse magari
vi starete già dando una risposta ma vi
chiedo di aspettare un attimo
guardiamo un altro esempio torniamo un
po indietro nel tempo
chi si ricorda questa pubblicità
perché io valgo è lo slogan che per
molti anni ha chiuso tutti gli spot
televisivi dei prodotti di bellezza
l'oreal
ma vi siete mai chiesti che cosa vuol
dire questa frase c'è perché è stata
pensata così per capirlo dobbiamo
pensare intanto a chi la pronuncia va
perché dagli anni settanta quando questa
campagna è stata lanciata dal real si
sono alternati in moltissimi testimonial
tra questi c'erano calciatori famosi
piloti e varie top model e questa
pubblicità funzionava perché alla base
c'è un meccanismo persuasivo molto forte
e allo stesso tempo veramente molto
semplice il ragionamento in tre passaggi
ma intanto io in questo caso non indica
nemmeno voi non indica nessuno di noi ma
la modella il pilota il calciatore per
cui la prima cosa che questa pubblicità
ci dice è che le persone che valgono
usano quel prodotto
poi ci dice un'altra cosa ci dice che
quella modella usa quel prodotto proprio
perché vale siccome lei vale allora usa
quel prodotto quindi come conseguenza
diretta io deduco automaticamente che se
uso quel prodotto allora anche io valgo
in più notiamo che il verbo scelto è
valere non è contare essere importanti o
qualcos'altro che poteva starci comunque
benissimo perché valere pensiamoci un
attimo per sponsorizzare un prodotto di
bellezza che cosa c'entrano un pilota e
un calciatore
capisco la modella o il modello ma il
pilota il calciatore cosa c'entrano la
risposta è proprio nel verbo valera
perché il fattore comune a tutti questi
personaggi è uno solo ed è la ricchezza
è il successo il risultato su di noi
quale come ci fa sentire una pubblicità
di questo tipo
beh di sicuro ci fa sentire inadeguati
provoca un senso di insicurezza di
insoddisfazione per la nostra vita
normale messa a confronto con quella di
questi personaggi talmente ricchi e
famosi da essere per noi irraggiungibili
e per chi se la ricorda diciamoci la
verità era una pubblicità abbastanza
fastidiosa abbastanza antipatica e il
motivo è che questa pubblicità abbassa
la nostra autostima ci fa sentire in
qualche modo inferiori ora guardiamo
quest'altra pubblicità
però dovremmo anche sentirla
ok ve la racconto io questo artista deve
creare il ritratto di queste donne e
deve crearne due deve creare il ritratto
della donna che si racconta e deve
creare il ritratto della stessa donna
che però viene descritta da qualcun
altro che l'ha vista pochi secondi prima
il risultato di questi sketch è che
quando la persona va a vedere il proprio
ritratto fatto da questo artista ma il
ritratto di questo artista in cui lei si
è descritta rispetto al contratto al
ritratto in cui è stata descritta da
qualcun altro
il risultato è completamente diverso
completamente diverso quello che questa
pubblicità ci vuole dire è che spesso
siamo molto più belle agli occhi degli
altri che non ai nostri occhi e che i
particolari del nostro corpo quelli che
spesso consideriamo dei difetti
in realtà sono proprio quello che ci
rende interessanti e guardando questa
pubblicità non ci viene voglia di essere
qualcun altro o di assomigliare a
qualcun altro
tutto il contrario ci viene voglia di
essere noi stessi
anzi da versione migliore di noi stessi
è un po diverso ma il principio è lo
stesso perché così come questa
pubblicità ci fa sentire bene anche la
pubblicità di coca cola ci fa sentire
bene ci fa sentire liberi e spensierati
ci fa sentire più uniti il punto che ce
ne rendiamo conto meno è che noi
vogliamo anche provare queste emozioni
quando beviamo una coca cola
esattamente come quando compriamo su
amazon vogliamo anche sentirci
intelligenti quando scegliamo un'agenda
moleskine vogliamo anche sentirci
creativi e smart e quando guidiamo un
harley davidson ci vogliamo sentire i
ribelli e indipendenti ma allora perché
demonizzare il marketing della
pubblicità
quando ci fanno provare le emozioni che
noi per primi vogliamo provare
beh forse perché il problema non è
l'emozione il marketing per vendere deve
creare emozioni e deve farlo perché
siamo noi per primi a voler provare
emozioni con i prodotti che compriamo il
problema non sono le emozioni ma quali
sono queste emozioni e soprattutto è chi
le decide perché i casi sono due
noi possiamo limitarci a fare gli
spettatori a guardare la pubblicità
punto senza farci domande
ok ma allora di sicuro saranno i
pubblicitari a decidere quali emozioni
dobbiamo provare e quali prodotti
dobbiamo comprare ea quel punto siamo
nelle loro mani perché il marketing e la
pubblicità e la psicologia applicata al
marketing sono tutti strumenti possono
essere usati anche per il bene oppure
solo per il business
ma se invece e questa è la seconda
possibilità noi provassimo a invertire
il processo è a partire dalla fine che
significa chiederci prima di tutto
qual è l'obiettivo di quella pubblicità
di qualsiasi pubblicità ci capita di
guardare che cosa vuole venderci un
prodotto un'esperienza entrambe le cose
oppure un'idea un comportamento
l'obiettivo sarà sempre comunque cercare
di convincerci a comprare qualcosa o
fare qualcosa ma la seconda domanda che
a mio avviso la più importante è come
sta cercando di farlo attraverso quale
tecnica attraverso quali emozioni
lo abbiamo visto per farci desiderare un
prodotto una pubblicità può farci
sentire inadeguati con una tecnica che
si chiama less than perfect appeal ti
ricorda che non sei perfetto che ti
manca qualcosa che puoi ottenere proprio
e solo con quel prodotto lì è abbastanza
facile riconoscere queste pubblicità da
quel senso di fastidio che ci provocano
a volte ce ne rendiamo conto
altre volte no ma dovremo provare a
farci caso
dopo aver visto queste pubblicità ci
sentiamo tendenzialmente peggio di come
ci sentivamo prima di vederla
ma per farci desiderare un prodotto che
può essere anche lo stesso prodotto una
pubblicità può farci sentire più sicuri
di noi stessi che non ci manca nulla per
essere felici perché ci basta essere
come siamo una pubblicità può farci
sentire più forti più determinati più
legati ai nostri sogni partire dalla
fine chiederci quali sono gli obiettivi
di quella pubblicità e come sta cercando
di raggiungerli significa ribaltare
completamente la prospettiva è metterci
un po nella testa di chi l'ha creata
quella pubblicità è un piccolo sforzo me
ne rendo conto ma che ci rende in grado
da qui in avanti di distinguere il
marketing che ci fa bene da quello che
non ci fa bene ea quel punto avremo
davvero il controllo perché saremo noi a
decidere quali emozioni vogliamo tenere
fuori perché non ci appartengono e non
vogliamo che ci appartengono e quali
emozioni invece vogliamo provare perché
vogliamo che facciano parte della nostra
vita anche attraverso la pubblicità
perché no e ovviamente anche attraverso
le cose che compriamo
[Applauso]